I have terminal bladder cancer I was
diagnosed in 2016
everyday I'm thinking about the end
should we be able to choose the manner
and timing of our own death
these campaigners some terminally ill
others with experience of assisted dying
believe the answer to this most profound
question is yes they brought their case
to Parliament as it debated the issue
for the first time in four years Anita
knows she may not have long to live I've
been a carer I've looked after people
with cancer and their deaths have been
pretty traumatic I'm pretty painful and
the thought of having that death for me
frightens the living daylights out of me
I don't want that for me and I don't
want it for my family either Kristi is
also dying of breast cancer for me it's
it's a human right I'm going to be dying
anyway and I think some people don't
understand I'm gonna be in the last few
weeks of my life
and all I'm saying is can I please avoid
that unnecessary suffering of the last
few weeks in the debate
Labour MP Paul Bloomfield told MPs his
father who had lung cancer
had taken his own life eight years ago
to the day knowing that he could with
support go at the time of his choosing
would have enabled him to stay longer
the Loret made it possible he would have
been able to say goodbye and go with his
family around him not in a carbon
monoxide soft garage while opinion polls
show a majority support assisted dying
some doctors are adamantly opposed
fearing it will put vulnerable patients
at risk if you have a terminal illness
or a degenerative condition your you've
got care costs for that if your
inheritance is being wound down by that
you want to provide for your family of
course you're going to feel the pressure
to think well maybe I should not be
selfish and actually ask for assisted
dying and very soon we'll see the right
to die becoming a duty to die
imperceptibly with more challenges to
the current law
and Parliament faces growing pressure to
decide if the right to death is as
fundamental as the right to life Paul
Kelso Sky News